[Music]
and 2013 Jaguar and Land Rover combined
into one company but nobody ever
expected Jaguar to roll out an SUV and
yet just two years later here it came
sporting the proud and illustrious big
cat logo in his badging if I as the car
tester android simmerman wonders if such
a workhorse for the masses can be a true
jaguar or is it more a pussycat going to
got the door on the outside the F pace
definitely has something of the Jaguar
about it the design is inspired by
Jaguars f-type sports coupe a the F pace
we tested had the our sport trim with
bi-xenon headlights and 19-inch rims
our car was powered by Jaguars first two
litre twin-turbo engine putting out 177
kilowatts and hurling the cars heft from
0 to 100 km/h in 7.2 seconds the twin
turbo charging gives it a nice wide rev
range
[Music]
inside we found a fully digital
instrument cluster
two toned leather seats and the driving
mode selectors danger pondering explains
that it's mainly the drivetrain that
gives the FPS its sporting credentials
it's all-wheel drive puts the weight
towards the back in contrast to the
all-wheel drive offered by many car
makers that's based on front-wheel drive
this makes a difference for instance
when heading into curves under steering
isn't so much a problem here and being
pushed from behind instead of a pull
from the front gives it more of a sports
car feel so this cat doesn't pussyfoot
around as much as trunk like an elephant
with its thumping curb weight of 1.8
tons even if the F piece make sure the
kilos aren't is noticeable they're still
there or stock on madness this is cuts
them down the F face can switch from
rear wheel to all-wheel drive in a tenth
of a second but it only does so when the
road gets slippery
under normal conditions only rear wheel
drive is engaged the F paces dynamic
drive mode can be used as the sports
setting or configured to individual
tastes
as unethical would Andre especially
likes about the dynamic mode is how it
sets the suspension it's a bit stiffer
but not so much as to make it
uncomfortable many car makers are
convinced that the suspension has to be
hard as a board and completely
uncomfortable to qualify a car as sporty
but he disagrees
since the F piece is an SUV we can do
with a bit more comfort than in real
sports cars a big help is the active
dynamic system which analyzes not only
the road surface but also the driving
style up to 500 times a second and
adjust the suspension accordingly the
equipment package costs around 1,500
euros extra in Germany and also includes
the configurable dynamic mode as far as
Andre is concerned they have faces more
a pussycat than a real predator after
all that's primarily because SUVs are
now targeted at the general car buying
public so they have to be able to please
everyone that keeps them from being
uncompromisingly sporting even so the
handling is definitely sporty-er than
with most SUVs so this is a good choice
for people looking for something a bit
sportier but not necessarily a higher up
race car a high center of gravity and
weight always takes away from the
sportiness of course but the F face is a
vital part of Jaguars model range since
it hit the showrooms the brand's
worldwide sales have risen by 77% and
the SUVs roll onward